Oh cuphead is a little difficult
whoa hello oh you think
cuphead you think cup Hennis hard hey
you haven't played i wanna be the guy I
don't think you have I don't think you
have have you played any other game in
your guy
Oh to do this listen you have to do this
stupid thing every time
huh you gotta do this whoa hello
hang out of this and then they go faster
and then this jump this jump is
impossible it is impossible I have done
the math okay I have a 4% chance of
making this jump four percent and after
I do the four percent jump I have to do
all that and I don't even know what to
do when that happens
oh look at that carpet it's a little
hard you know dare I say this game is
just like Dark Souls even though it came
out before dark I can't even do the
first job they managed to put
a flippity damn rocket on the moon okay
I can make this jump I know I can make
this jump
I need to make this no that's where I
run okay I see you now
I see you now I can visualize I can
visualize the jump there is hope
Flik gamma D Doogie slapper Abba flaca
come on what do I do
how how he just went for it dude why he
just double jump through it
you can't just double jump through it
[Music]
oh you just have to do that oh yes oh my
god
[Laughter]
[Music]
why did no one down me that's fine
we gotta kill these banks and I don't
know how okay all right here we go here
we go here we go here we go come on come
on I never want to play this thing again
and this can actually happen okay
where's the back
got him slacker like a like a black okay
there's another one there's another one
where are you the creature of the [ __ ]
coming soon to a Cineplex near you I
should have thought from the look of the
poor fellow's if he died of fright be
aware that terrifying creature even
remain and Oliver Reed they where that
preacher of the [ __ ] creature of the
[ __ ] whatever I can do it now
I can do it easy first try watching
whatever first try baby first oh my god
you [ __ ] where are you I know you're
coming from I know you're coming from
where I bring it bring it
frag Oh upstairs they came from upstairs
you came from down
[Music]
it's fine
it's all good it's all good man oh he's
got good
he's got good everybody it's very
beginning to believe
[Music]
Christian channel the ad revenue it will
all be for nothing
and so began Peter Paris slow descent
into madness until eventually he would
transform into a pre care of the [ __ ]
it's gonna come from underneath you will
attack from underneath he will attack
from underneath what that flicker
[Music]
we're not done yet
we're not done yet we're not done yet
why the flicker am i shooting that way
okay okay there might be more bats Felix
Bueller why didn't the hit it hit it you
you thought I couldn't do it my hatest
doubted me
[Music]
well another challenge we have saved
they have saved the damn game we have
saved it how many deaths was that how
many deaths was tonight check
[Music]
options play hide the menu disable I
don't I'm just gonna quit it okay
hopefully it's saved okay if they didn't
even count any of the deaths last
episode just keep that in mind
so this jump looks pretty
straightforward
I don't know okay
[Music]
how in the world how and how how how how
how has changed
sorry why do they have to make the first
jumping possible oh I get it
oh my god divide elect some and plate
oh you know no no no no no no no I
refuse
we take me back thank you yes yes yes
Queen yes can I get a hallelujah
hallelujah hello hello signore
thank you thank you you didn't
splendid must master Wayne lemon a look
at that gem is how do we activate the
arm huh how do we activate the arm
goodbye arm goodbye not on my watch
why I'm going I can't go there okay all
right we got apples we got our apples we
got some first strike first strike first
strike Sarah Sarah Sarah - Sarah
zero dance that's a bird [ __ ] off bird I
hate you okay okay okay I got it I got
it I got it King apples
you gotta get the views
views
[Music]
no come on come on
I show them I will record everything
more stupid apples stupid zombies stupid
babbles go away show show do the damn
jump Felix do the double jump no this is
bad
oh there's no same there so save yet are
you fracking it back
[Music]
don't need a gun to get respect to get
respect
my papa
and my enemies my enemies I won't oh god
it's a P and I have to do all of them
nothing
and thank you no thank you goodbye